it was never expected that this brutal
work could happen between burhan and
hemeti and rightly so because behind it
really which many people do not see and
do not know and maybe by now they have
known is behind this is actually the
islamist the islamists who were under
albashir the national Islamic front and
they are still there they were
hibernating behind and they took
advantage of this and triggered the the
crisis between uh bruhan and hemeti and
this is where many people are shocked
attacking by shock particularly Sudanese
themselves those the experts who know
the Sudanese politics Will really find
out that this was totally something that
came up like that struck like lightning
between the two but it is held the
islamists who were behind it who want to
come back to Power in the in the Sudan